[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so as you mentioned I'm going to be
talking about simulation in particular I
think that one thing that happens in
companies is you learn to do a B testing
and like you know don't get me wrong
they be testing is awesome but but I
think there's a tendency to think that
it's the right tool all the time and
what I'm going to try to talk to you
about is how there are alternatives and
for us we had a situation that wasn't
really metabolic asking and in real
estate in the act of buying and selling
houses and we solved it using
simulations so first I think I know the
answer to this but can you please raise
your hand if you've ever run an a/b test
before okay okay almost all the hands
are out sorry it can you can you keep
them raised please okay thank you now
follow-on question did it go off without
a hitch okay most of the hands are down
I still see a couple up and so you know
hitch is like there's an experiment that
you tried and maybe there was a pretty
bad user experience I've experienced
this many times
I won't tell you what companies are what
what experiments but I think a lot of us
can identify with this for the maybe two
people who had their hands up I don't
know how much you'll get from the stock
it sounds like you're experts so I think
a lot of people have in mind with the
hammer they'd be testing you know you
you imagine you have this picture of
beautiful straight nails but for most of
us I think this is what you end up
getting you know they're they're bent
and in various ways and you could always
be better next time and you have to try
again so you can imagine a pyramid of
causal inference where as you go down
the pyramid you get increasing
confidence in your results but they come
at increasing cost and you can certainly
quibble with this it's not super precise
or anything but at the top is the
observational analysis so yesterday from
Muhammad's talk if you think of your one
at Pinterest you're counting things
right if you're not doing anything
really sophisticated this is the
correlation is causation crowd maybe I'm
claiming that simulation kind of [ __ ]
in here so you can be a little bit more
confident in the results but you have to
do a little bit more work to to get them
then you can look at quasi experiments
so you're not actually randomizing
anything but you've got a stream of
observational data and you know maybe
somewhere in that stream you can
identify situations that we're almost as
good as random so I think the
econometrics toolkit and then finally at
the bottom of the pyramid
there's the vaunted ad test the gold
standard I would say it's the highest
cost but you can have the highest
confidence and your results it's not to
say that it's it's perfect you know a B
testing of networks is really hard for
instance but I think this is roughly
correct so you've got kind of maybe a
blindly analyzing data and then the bent
nails and I'm going to talk about
simulations and you can use simulations
to throw out poor candidates for your AP
test you can use it as a guide in order
to have better nails straight nails so
this talk is going to follow the
following structure I know not everyone
especially in San Francisco has been
through the buying and selling process
before so I have to give a little bit of
an overview there open door does things
pretty differently we buy houses from
sellers and then it's on us to later
find market buyers to resell to so
that's important because the fundamental
question that caused us to develop this
methodology was around understanding
what the risk is we incur when we buy
the house from the seller that we have
to later resell to a market buyer and
then I'm going to talk about why AV
testing didn't work for us and have
simulations save the day in this
particular example
ian's something to take away for the
talk I hope is I would like to try to
come up with a couple general principles
for how simulation may or may not help
you
and then the thinly-veiled recruiting
[ __ ] or a slide about the company and
how we're hiring and everything so Who
am I
I run a support group at work my name is
Nelson it's been like two weeks since my
last AP test and I've run a lot of views
over the years at various companies
Facebook Metamarkets Google now I'm a be
testing in real estate at open door and
I'm going to cover how to I guess
turbocharged you're a/b testing by you
know simulating outcomes instead okay so
what's open door about moving is a
really hard and stressful process
especially around home buying and
selling so we're trying to streamline
that process as much as possible it's a
really big industry so there was a talk
about you know many terabytes part
cluster at Facebook that's a lot of
bytes it's a lot of dollars like 25
trillion dollars is the dollar value of
all houses in the United States it
touches a lot of people almost two
thirds of Americans own their own their
own homes and it's what people spend the
most money on every year you spend an
average of twenty thousand dollars a
year on housing costs and people buy and
sell a lot of houses 1.4 trillion
dollars in in aggregate and the United
States and the fees alone are
mind-boggling Lee large numbers 100
billion dollars goes to realtors as as
commission so the way it works right now
I'm going through the process like has
anyone else butter sold before okay so
if you see a grimace on my face then
it's like dredging up these bad memories
I apologize but the way it works right
now is if you're looking to sell your
house you will you decide you want to
you find a realtor who's going to
Shepherd you through the process your
guide and you have to invest thousands
of dollars in fixing up your house
making it nice for people who are going
to walk in then you list your house and
then this is when the waiting game
begins if you're lucky you'll be able to
find someone who's interested in buying
it quickly otherwise it takes a long
time by the time you get to a serious
buyer and this doesn't happen for
everyone you will have conceded on
several points not least of which is
price also you know when you close and
other contingencies for instance and
it's not even over yet people can fall
out of contract and this happens and
about one-seventh of cases and if you're
one of the lucky ones who manages to get
all the way to closing it's taken you
I think 120 days on average in the u.s.
San Francisco is not representative of
the rest of the country and disrespect
and if you're looking to buy the
processes
similarly frustrating you spend a lot of
time doing research you work with the
realtor is going to help you through the
process but you're the one who's walking
into houses trying to find your perfect
house and this is chances are going to
be the largest financial transaction of
your life and so there's a lot of doubt
and uncertainty what if I buy the house
and I have to invest twenty or thirty
thousand dollars in a new roof what if I
don't line up the financing I have my
eyes set on this house like it's I can
imagine
living my life in it and the bank won't
want agreed to lend me money
so this decide takes 100 plus days to
and this affects a lot of people every
year over five million Americans so we
decided to rethink this experience and
selling with open door is pretty easy
you go to our website you enter your
address fill out a short survey about
your house and we'll give you within a
couple hours an offer backed by data
and then you just fill out the rest of
the contract online so that the key
difference is you're selling your house
to us and then now it's up to us to find
a market buyer and the way that works is
you start going to our website you click
on one of the cities that we're
operating in filter down to find your
dream house and we have exclusive
inventory and for peace of mind we give
warranty and a 30-day money-back
guarantee so you can refund it for the
full purchase price within 30 days and
then you just fill out the rest online
so this is we're incurring a lot of risk
in this process and we use simulations
to try to deeply understand this
question of when we acquire a house how
how risky is it for us to resell it so
I'm going to present - I think
motivating examples there's one home
here that looks really nice and fancy it
has some desert landscaping if you look
inside there is a solarium with a view
of the pool and like a gorgeous pool
there's fountains and other water
features and like mar-a-lago or
something like that so unsurprisingly
it's at a higher price point so how long
do you think it would take for us to be
able to find a market buyer for this
house it's it's beautiful any guesses
like one month two months three so many
months okay you're you're right over six
months on the market so the higher price
point means that there's a smaller buyer
pool who can afford it and you know
maybe it's on a large lot which is only
really possible in the outskirts of town
again it's it's less convenient to get
there also could depend on the time of
year people don't usually move around
the holidays so this beautiful house
took a really long time to sell
and here's a second example this house
looks it's nice you know nothing wrong
with it but it's it's just not as fancy
as the first one and it has a backyard
and you know I'm living in a shoebox
here in the city so like any backyard
even if it doesn't have a pool is is an
upgrade it's a lower price point so any
guesses as to how long this one took to
sell yes okay one one month I think that
was the time to close and I think there
was an interested buyer immediately so
pretty much what I said about the first
house I think the opposite is true here
probably in a central location lower
price point there are many more buyers
who could afford it I don't remember
what what time of year it was but with
these two examples in mind this is our
risk philosophy so we we there the risk
and trying to later resell the house and
as we saw earlier it can the cost can be
highly variable so the cost in number of
months for the first house was over six
months and then second house sold very
quickly and we think that it's fair to
charge the seller based on their
expected cost so what this means is if
you had come with us with a really you
know fancy custom high-end house it'll
take us longer to find a market buyer
and we we charge a higher fee does that
make sense yes yeah yeah in this case it
would be a higher percentage so like you
know maybe 10 or 11% up from the
standard 6% yeah thank you so if we
wanted to turn this into math a little
bit first there's a really quick lesson
in in metrics the conversion for a
seller to sell if to accept the offer as
a function of the fee that we charge is
decreasing so if we charge a higher fee
than sellers and unsurprisingly are less
willing to entertain the offer
if you've heard a very low fee then
they're they're happy to partake in the
service however profit is an increasing
function to see the the higher fee we
charge the more money we make and these
are going to be the two key metrics that
we're going to look at for the rest of
the talk there are in tension with one
another higher fee increases one but
decreases the other and we we kind of
want both right so if you were to write
down the math problem that you're trying
to solve it might look something like
this you want to maximize the volume
that you do measured in the number of
houses that you acquire and you want to
make sure that you don't lose too much
money doing this maybe in 1999 the last
part was given a little bit less lot and
this maximization problem is going to be
over the space of all pricing functions
there's a expression about how writing
down the problem gets you halfway to the
solution or something we did not find
had to be true in this case so there are
number of issues with with this the
first is that if you think about all the
different ways that you could need to
measure risk and in charge for houses
it's even basic parameterizations are
infinite dimensional so how do you know
which ones to even consider you can you
can model various parts of the problem
so you can have a liquidity model and
then a pricing model how do you know how
much weight to put on each one this is
the treatment space is very large and
assuming you even whittled it down to
one candidate that you thought was
pretty good how do you test this well I
can probably ask any of the 90 plus
percent of the people who raised their
hands earlier you know let's think about
what an a/b testing approach would look
like so first you have to determine your
experimental unit and you can randomize
on offers that is when an offer comes in
you'll randomly assign either one
pricing model or another pricing model
that's pretty straightforward
and then the two metrics that we looked
at conversion rolls up into number of
houses and then full profit you add it
and then you get profit - so in
principle this seems like it would work
but let me talk about metric measurement
lag the first number quantity what this
represents is when we make sellers
offers how likely they are to accept our
offers and people usually decide within
a couple days and our offers also expire
so we measure this pretty quickly it's
not like if you're a search engine you
can measure clicks in seconds but
compared with the other number
I'll take days so then we go on to
profit and how do we measure in book
profit well a seller has to accept our
offer
that's a revenue we renovate the house
make repairs whatever we listed on the
market and then we have to wait a
variable amount of time and this time is
often measured in months so I think if
you were to summarize the situation with
one picture it would look something like
this exactly how we felt so two two main
problems the first is that you a be
testing won't really help you whittle
down your candidate space we are doing a
couple hundred houses a month and
depending on the expected effect sizes
we're looking at you really only have
enough power to test maybe you know one
or two candidates so it doesn't help in
this situation
and the second is that even if you
started your a/b test yesterday then
you're waiting five or six months you
know at a minimum before you start
getting useful results so our a/b
testing hammer we have to put it back
and then find another tool from the tool
shed
there's backpropagation or something the
wrench sorry okay so so what does our
simulation look like
well we have historical transaction data
so a stream of people who are expressing
interest in selling their houses they're
listing them on the market and then some
of them will have been successful in
selling their houses so they list their
houses and we're trying to simulate what
we would have done at a certain point in
time and based on our philosophy the way
we do that is we want to estimate our
costs so we think this house was going
to be very possibly for us to resell or
not very costly and we hold ourselves
accountable to what actually transpired
so if a house ended up taking a really
long time to sell and we thought that
was going to be the case then this is
good this idea if you do machine
learning back-testing it's the exact
same thing and the only real difference
is you're you're doing it backtest for
the business so there's a little bit of
business logic in the buying process
simulation in particular we have to
model how a user would react to our
offer but it's the you know exact same
idea nothing really new here I think so
for the two houses we looked at this is
what the process would would be the
first house the very expensive fancy
house because it took so long to sell
let's say it was fifty thousand dollars
for us we financed the majority of our
houses so we have to pay an interest
rate every day and there also other
upkeep costs and property taxes so you
can pretty much translate the time into
into resale cost and we're going to
compare two different pricing models one
of which consistently underestimates
resale costs so here it's estimating ten
thousand dollars and the two metrics
that we care about seller conversion or
the probability that the seller will
accept is 0.9 it's very high because the
seller is thinking wow it's like such an
expensive house it's going to be hard
for me to resell I want to take
advantage of this and unsurprisingly we
lose a lot of money in this case so
$40,000 for instance and there's another
model our baseline pricing model which
does better but it's more accurate
so it estimates $55,000 in expected
resale cost the seller is less happy in
this case and we booked a small profit
so they're only willing to accept with
probability 0.14 the second house it
sold in one months so we can translate
it into $10,000 for instance the pricing
model that underestimates costs
estimates 5,000 and we lose some money
but you have a happy seller and in the
baseline case we we still lose a little
bit of money and it's less likely that
that will acquire the house so this is
what it looks like for two two houses we
on our simulation said it's hundreds or
thousands of houses and the conversion
rolls up into an expected number of
houses that you acquire and then the
profit just rolls up additively in this
case the undervaluation one we would
have lost forty plus five so forty five
thousand dollars and we would have one
point eight houses on non average so
what you can do is you can plot the
result of the simulation in trade off
space so you have dollars on the y-axis
and volume on the x-axis and the
undervaluation sorry the D model the
pricing model that consistently
underestimates the coughs we end up
losing a lot of money there but we do a
lot of volume making it up on volume and
then the baseline case relative to that
making some money at the expense of some
volume what you could do is you could
start with the baseline and you could
shade the prices up a little bit so
whatever the baseline model says you add
some constant value for instance and you
could end up with another point in this
trade-off space and then you can shade
it down so you're making less money but
you're doing more volume and you end up
with another point and you can keep
doing this and you can draw out a curve
of business trade-offs and you repeat
the same process
the pricing model that was consistently
under estimating the resale costs so we
note that one model dominates the other
that is for a given quantity you can
make more money and the way this this
works is a you can imagine if you have a
business process where you're optimizing
costs then for the same quantity its it
flows directly into margin in this case
it's the result of a better machine
learning model so the way that you can
expand this frontier to is not just
based on cost minimization but you can
also better better machine learning
models translate into better business
outcomes in general it's not always true
so this is what the simulation gets you
and in the a/b testing world you only
measure these two points after six
months for instance and the best you can
really do is you can draw a line through
them so you have an immense amount of
clarity into the end of the trade-offs
you can tell the CEO this is where we
are operating right now and depending on
the business priorities we could be here
or there what it lets us do with a be
testing is we can identify that the
undervaluation model it probably had
worse machine learning metrics but in
business trade-off space it's dominated
by the existing model so you eliminate
it as a as a candidate and you don't
even bother with with the a/b test in
this case and so you can run as many
simulations as you want you eliminate
all the possible all the candid and all
the candidates that are dominated and
then you you think about the problem
again so we've known how to back test
for a very long time in machine learning
this gets you back testing with business
metrics which is kind of cool you're not
talking about our MSC or a UC or log
loss you're talking about quantity
volume and margin and stuff like that
and because you're doing a back test it
takes seconds versus the
forward a B test which could take many
months for the results that trickle in
so the main cost is computational but in
it's very precise but how good is the
the quality of the results how accurate
is it really and I will return to that
in a moment but I think another really
cool thing that the simulation framework
gets you is the ability to do a better
job planning so I think one thing that
happens in a lot of companies is you
have some measure of like these are the
metrics right now this is where I am and
then you want to set a goal you know I
want to be X percent better in the next
quarter or something and you might do
something like this I've always taken
issue with this because it can be kind
of demotivating if you don't know if
it's even possible or not you know great
like that that's the goal are we going
to be able to meet it is it within the
realm of feasibility who knows so
there's a thing that you can do it's
kind of cool with the simulation
framework that that goes like this you
write down the performance of a perfect
model and the way you do that is in our
house example this is the actual resale
cost we experienced a perfect model
would know that ahead of time so we
would estimate $50,000 and it does and
that admits the to metric measurements
the conversion probability and then
profit we estimated it perfectly so it's
zero dollars and for the second house it
actually ended up costing ten thousand
dollars and you get that perfectly so
this gets you the zero profit point on
that curve and you can sweep out above
and below it by increasing this amount
so from 10,000 to 11,000 to 12,000 and
then from 10,000 to 9,000 8,000 to sweep
out this Oracle trade-off curve now this
is also is a bit unrealistic because all
problems have some amount of irreducible
error in them and the measurement of the
best performance of the best model in
the real world is the the Bayes error
so you can come up with this base
trade-off curve which is not the
performance of a perfect model but the
performance of the best model given the
reducible error and what you can do now
is again we have this mapping from
machine learning metric space so our MSE
to business metrics so you could say I
know what my current rmse is and I know
you know I can guess what the Bayes
error is and now I want to try to bridge
that gap by 20% and you can get
something that looks like it actually
looks very similar to the curve that we
wrote down before but I think the way
that you got the framing is different
and I think that's what matters so you
you estimate what you can theoretically
achieve and I think it's a little bit
more motivating it's like within the
realm of possibility you said in an
improvement in machine learning space
and it translates it directly into you
know if I'm able to ship this model
that's X percent better and you see then
this is the business implication so I
don't mean to downplay the difficulty of
actually getting that 20% improvement
the Netflix prize comes to mind they set
an improvement of 10% and it took three
years to hit it I think if they had set
it at 20% then all the fine folks at
Netflix who are here would be excitedly
talking about oh you know we're it like
11.1 and 11.2% now I think there's some
doubts about whether 20% is actually
achievable on that problem given all the
millions of people hours that have been
put into the problem so far so this is
just another thing it might be a little
bit more motivating you can at least
have a bound on how well you can
ultimately do based on your modeling
improvements and maybe it's the case
that the perfect model only yields a
very small business improvement in which
case you don't even want to invest in it
so I think it's important for that
reason
okay so the elephant in the room is how
accurate is this approach we've seen the
trade-offs curves are extremely precise
but who knows how accurate they are and
I'm gonna take a pass maybe at trying to
answer this question and say you can use
other techniques to get at the accuracy
so where we were with the hammer of a/b
testing is you you want to do it right
but in practice something typically goes
wrong and this seemed like a really good
metaphor this thing actually exists it's
called a nail assist so if you use it in
concert with a hammer then you get
straight nails I don't mean to hammer
you over the head with with metaphor but
I thought it was appropriate so where we
were is you've got this pyramid of
causal inference and with analysis you
can supercharge your a/b testing so the
conclusion of the story for us in the
real estate example is we ran these many
many grids of simulations we came up
with a candidate that we are excited
about we were able to offer our service
for more people that is do more volume
to no detriment in in profit and now now
what right what about the accuracy how
much do you really trust those results
so I think it's a very get these
decisions should be made on a
case-by-case basis but if we wanted to
further results with the gold standard
that is we we have a candidate we run an
a/b test then we're back to the first
problem sorry the second problem we had
which is you still have to wait six
months right
we had enough confidence in our results
that we decided to do 100% launch and
then we followed it up with a quasi
experiments I guess to try to make sure
that the less lagged metric was in line
with the simulation predictions and then
as the other metrics roll in you want to
make sure that it doesn't go off the
rails
and depending on your situation the
business trade-offs I think in
healthcare you might want to be a little
bit more confident in your results but
it's really up to you wherever you want
to stop so for us we didn't quite make
it to the a/b test we stopped at the
quasi experiment and we were satisfied
enough in our results but I think it's
really situational so how can we apply
this more generally in our case we had
historical transaction data so houses
that listed unsold we had a user model
and the way that we tried to estimate
the prices we would have offered is
based on our costs and then we held
ourselves accountable to the actual
outcome what actually transpired for the
house I think the two main ingredients
one is the data part you don't strictly
need historical data I think you just
really need a data generating process
and I think the second key ingredient
and this framework is for us we
simulated or buying process but more
generally you want a user model so for
the first part how do you think about
the data generating process
everyone everyone logs data there's a
talk after this about about logging that
I'm really excited about so the way we
replayed our our historical data in real
estate was we had a list of houses that
that listed and sold so we used past
housing transactions if your your lifts
do goober then you surely have logs of
passengers who are opening opening up
their phones trying to request rides if
you're Google or Bing you similarly have
people searching you have search
sessions so what terms are people
searching for how do they navigate and
so on and you also have the stock of
potential ads that could have shown but
possibly did not show but but might
under a given perturbation of the
auction if you had boosted the bid for
instance so
simple version I think is people have
logs you can just iterate over the logs
that's that's pretty good and for the
user model and real estate for us we
were trying to model the probability
that a seller would sell their house to
us given the fee that we charge and this
was downward sloping and people don't
want to pay more money obviously if
you're a right sharing service then
maybe the relevant user model is the
probability that a writer is going to
accept the ride given the price that
you're offering and also how far away
the driver is and if you're a search
engine then you get paid by the click
and you care a lot about modeling the
pub believe it a user will click on an
ad given everything you know about the
user and everything you know about the
ad so oh I wanted to I wanted to say
that this is not a silver bullet and I
think another key assumption is that
what you're trying to simulate is
modeled in the user model for instance
uber recently launched a new UI and that
is not amenable to this kind of
simulation because well if if they're
modeling the probability that you'll
accept a ride given the price in the UT
a and not UI then it's it's blind it has
no power to detect anything right you'll
you'll say hey I'm going to simulate the
new UI launch but the user model doesn't
take that into account
so you see no difference so yeah we
wanted to make that clear in closing I
think if you remember one thing it's the
please a be test responsibly and just
consider simulating before testing so
just a little bit about the team and the
problems were working on at open door we
were founded almost three years actually
just over three years ago we're buying
and selling a couple hundred houses a
month and we have a couple hundred
employees fifty data scientists and
engineers and we're working on causal
inference problems like this trying to
better model the price of houses
ingest as much real estate data as
possible if it can help us better
understand the risks associated in
buying and selling houses or
understanding our valuation of the
houses and we are hiring if you want to
talk about anything my email address is
Nelson an open-door comm I'm also going
to hold office hours right after this
talk I think upstairs and many people
contributed my awesome colleagues to the
stock so thanks to them and I think I
have well maybe not time for questions
because we're a little bit late but I'll
leave it up the end thank you cool Thank
You Nelson I think we can take one
question or okay 200 sorry if you have
like ideas about how to use this in
other use cases or have done it before I
would love love to talk to you about it
because I find this stuff super
interesting so so during your talk there
were two things that kind of came to
mind that make me wonder about your
testing strategy one is it's backward
looking and what happens is the dynamics
of the economy change and then the other
one is are there any kind of concerns
like certain regulatory concerns around
you know your models potentially
discriminating against people based on
geography or things that might be
proxies for you know protected groups
oh so you're absolutely right in the
first point I think John was just saying
about the standard disclaimer with all
the stuff is that the past performance
is not reflective of a future for the
regulatory stuff I know if you're doing
regulated work like I think in financing
I don't touch that but I we have lawyers
and I think we're very sensitive to
those concerns but I don't know any
anything more
so I'm curious have you run into co-star
issues where when you enter a new market
just don't have data to do simulations
yeah we definitely do so we rely on
other data sources that aren't our own
where we don't have any operational
distri yeah that's that's a big problem
for us